good morning kick it's Tuesday so
there's this line in the movie Rushmore
where a soldier walking through a jungle
says I ain't even here Sergeant I'm in
Cheyenne Wyoming then that's kind of
become a metaphor in our family for
whenever we're really into writing or
making art or whatever because that's
kind of what creative expression is to
me it's a way of escaping the body type
prison of myself and traveling to other
places like Cheyenne Wyoming so yeah
full disclosure I ain't even here right
now I'm in Cheyenne Wyoming like a
couple nights ago I said in my sleep
chapter 2 is not working which is not by
the way oh wait that reminds me remember
a couple months ago when nerdfighteria
helped raise the alarm about Johnson and
Johnson trying to extend the patent of
their antibiotic bedaquiline well the
stop TV partnership just announced that
in most countries with high rates of
tuberculosis the price of bedaquiline
will drop thanks to generic competition
by over 50 percent which is amazing news
I think ultimately what I find so
fascinating about tuberculosis is that
until quite recently it it was as
Charles Dickens put it the disease that
wealth never warded off like for almost
all of human history Kings died of
tuberculosis the richest man of the 19th
century died of tuberculosis and then
rather suddenly it became a disease that
wealth almost always Wards off and so
for a long time in much of the world we
saw tuberculosis as a disease of
civilization and wealth and privilege
and success and now in so far as much of
the rich world thinks about tuberculosis
at all it's seen as a disease of poverty
and marginalization and that's pretty
weird it's also a reminder that disease
is not just a medical phenomenon it's
also a social one like how we imagine
diseases matters so I've been in
Cheyenne Wyoming trying to figure out
how that happened and how to tell the
story of it like how did we end up in a
world where in the 21st century the
deadliest infectious disease is curable
that's never happened before the 20th
Century's deadliest disease wasn't
curable neither was the 19th century of
the 18th centuries you could go all the
way back through the centuries it's
literally unprecedented and trying to
understand that and figure out how to
tell that story is very different from
like making up a story in my mind but
it's also not that different because
whether I'm writing fiction or an essay
or a video script or whatever what I'm
really trying to do is like make sense
of a world that does not really lend
itself to sense and that feeling of
trying to like piece together various
things until it makes a picture that
makes sense to me is very fulfilling but
I don't actually think it's what I like
about writing I think ultimately deep
down what I love most about writing Hank
is that it's something to think about
it's a way of visiting Cheyenne Wyoming
escaping myself and being able to worry
about something else for a while like at
11 PM when I would otherwise be going
through my usual worries and
mortifications I can think about the
story I can get out of this flesh sack
that is also a bacterial colony and
visit Cheyenne Wyoming but then
eventually there does come a point where
I'm not really here I'm in Cheyenne
Wyoming and like even when I'm Dreaming
I'm dreaming of Cheyenne and that can be
a pretty intense experience but it won't
last that long like next week I'm 100
sure that I won't be in Cheyenne Wyoming
all the time because one of the things
that I've been working on will like uh
be happening but I'm not allowed to talk
about that yet I hate it when YouTubers
are like something's gonna happen but
then I can't talk about it because but I
actually can't talk about it gosh what
was the point of this video Cheyenne
Wyoming is a metaphor not a real place
go to Cheyenne Wyoming whenever you can
but don't stay there forever all right
that said I'm going back to Cheyenne
Wyoming but one more thing Hank I really
like your beard I think it's great that
you look different now because like you
are different now you're moving through
a profound and difficult experience and
you're looking good doing it man like I
never thought I'd say this but I'm
excited to have a brother who might be
able to go full Tom Selleck Hank I'll
see you on Friday